[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK FELKER: Hello,
I'm Nick Felker.
You may remember me
from such YouTube videos
as "Integrating Smart Home
Devices with the Google
Assistant," which you can
find in the description below.
Today, I'm going to talk about
how to use the new report state
API to create a better user
experience for smart displays
and mobile phones.
When you integrate your smart
home devices with the Google
Assistant, these
devices are registered
in the Home Graph, a database
which stores and provides
contextual information about
the user's home and the devices
inside.
The Google Assistant sends
commands to your web hook,
receiving intents,
and responding
by taking action on devices
or responding with information
about a user's devices.
When I tell my Google Home,
make my workshop cooler,
my server will
receive a query intent
to get the current temperature,
then an execute intent
to set the thermostat
to a lower set point.
The Assistant is now
coming to smart displays,
offering a rich visual
interface to users,
allowing them to
control their devices,
and check on their state.
In a visual interface,
users usually
expect a more
immediate response,
because they're looking
at the screen instead
of doing something else.
Waiting for a query request
to get the current set point
will result a
noticeable visual delay.
To improve the
user experience, we
are introducing a new API
that will allow Smart Home
developers to report the
state of their devices
to the Home Graph proactively.
This will allow the
Google Assistant
to reduce the number
of server calls
and result in a more streamlined
experience for developers
and users.
In the Google Cloud Console,
create a new service account
key.
This will be used to make secure
connections between your server
and the Home Graph that transfer
a device's current state.
You will use this key when
making a call using gRPC.
The request will be signed
with the private key
from your service account.
You can also send states using
a post request and adjacent web
token.
s you report the
device state, we
recommend setting the
entire state of the device.
For example, if you
have a smart switch,
you only need to send the on
state for the on/off trait.
When reporting the state for
the temperature setting trait,
you'll need to send not just
the thermostat temperature set
point but also the thermostat
temperature ambient field.
Now, when I take a look
at my smart display,
I can see the temperature
of the thermostat updating
in real time.
Cool.
We have a sample on
GitHub for a dashboard
which lets you view test devices
and states that are currently
in the Home Graph
to let you debug.
Now that you're assigning
the device state,
you will also need
to know when to stop
sending the device state.
When the user unlinks their
data from the Google Assistant,
you will receive a
disconnect intent
so that you can update
your server logic.
Now, you should be all set
for giving users a better
experience with the port state.
I can make the workshop a
little cooler, make the workshop
a lot cooler, make the
workshop super cool.
Ah, perfect.
[SLEIGH BELLS RING]
I hope this video
helped explain how
to get started with integrating
your Smart Home devices
with the Google Assistant.
Visit the Documentation to
learn more about Smart Home
and join our
community to discuss
this with other developers.
Thank you for watching.
Make sure to subscribe
to this channel
for more awesome videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]